you uh
you mentioned that you used to love
literature when you were younger and you
were even um
or hoping to be
a writer yourself that was the
motivation
and
some of the books i've seen that you
listed um that were
inspiring to you was was from russian
literature like uh i think tolstoy
dostoevsky solzhenitsyn
yeah right um maybe in general you can
speak to your fascination with russian
literature or yeah in general will you
pick up from those
not surprised you picked up on the
russian literature i'm sorry your
background but
uh
when i when i you should be surprised
that didn't make the entire conversation
about this that's that's the real
surprise when when uh
i didn't really
become a
physicist or
want to go in science until i started
college so when i was younger i
i was good at math and
that kind of stuff but i didn't really i
came from a family nobody went to
college and i didn't have any mentors
so but i'd like to read when i was
really young and so when i was very
young i i read i always carried around a
pocketbook and read it
and uh
my mother read these mystery stories and
i got bored by those eventually and then
i discovered real literature i don't
know what age but about 12 or 13.
and so then i started reading
uh good literature and there's nothing
better than russian literature of course
and like reading
already reading
good literature so i
i
read
quite a bit of
russian literature
at that time
and so you asked me about the well
i don't know i say a few words said
dostoevsky so what what about dostoevsky
for me
um
dostoevsky was important
into i mean i've read a lot of
literature because it's kind of the
other thing i do with my life and
he made two
incredible in addition to his own
literature
he influenced literature tremendously by
having
uh
i don't know how to pronounce polyphony
so he's the first real serious author
that had uh multiple narrators
and that's a that he absolutely is the
first
and he also was the first
he began existential literature
so
the most important book that i've read
in the last year when i've been forced
to be isolated
was existential literature it was i
decided to reread
uh camus the plague
oh yeah that's a great book it's a great
book and it's right now to read it it's
fine i think that book is about love
actually
a love for his humanity it is but it has
all the men it has all the
you should if you haven't read it in
recent years i had read it before of
course but
to read it during this because it's
about a plague so it's really fantastic
to be done but that reminds me of
you know he was a great existentialist
but the beginning of existential
literature was dostaff
yeah so in addition to his own you know
great novels he had a tremendous impact
on on uh
on literature and there's also for
disease unlike most of their
existentialists
he was
at least in part religious i mean their
uh religiousity would permeated his
idea i mean one of my favorite books of
his is the idiot and
he's which is a christ-like figure in
there well there's prince miskin is that
michigan yeah yeah michigan yeah in
michigan yeah that's that's one uh thing
about there you write it in english i
presume yeah yeah so that's the names
that's what gets a lot of people is
there's so many names so hard to
pronounce they have to remember all of
them
it's like uh you have the same problem
but he was a great character so that
yeah i kind of uh
i have a
connection with him because i often
then the title of the book
the idiot is
i kind of i often call myself an idiot
is that how i feel i feel so naive about
this world and i
i'm not sure
i'm not sure why that is maybe it's
genetic or so on but i
um
i have a connection a spiritual
connection to that character to michigan
to michigan yeah that you're just in but
he was far from energy yet
no we in some sense in some sense
but in another sense maybe not of this
in another sense he was yeah i mean it
was a bumbler
but uh you also mentioned solzhenitsyn
yeah very interesting yes he did uh and
and he always confused me of course he
was really uh
really important and uh
writing about the
stalin
and
first getting in trouble and then he
later he is he he wrote about stalin in
a way i forget what it was what the book
was
in a way that was very
critical of london
yeah he uh he's evolved through the
years he actually showed support for
putin eventually it was a very
interesting
uh transition he took no uh journey he
took through thinking about russia and
the soviet union
but
i think what i get from him is basic um
it's like a victor franco has a man
search for meaning i have a similar kind
of sense
of um
of the cruelty of human nature yeah
cruelty of indifference
but also the ability to find happiness
in the small joys of life
that that's something there's nothing
like a prison camp that makes you
realize
you could still be happy with a very
very little well yeah he was
his description of kind of how to make
uh
how to go through a day and actually
enjoy it in a prison camp it's pretty
amazing
yeah oh and some prison camp i mean it's
the worst of the worst of the worst and
also just uh i i you know you do think
about
the role of authoritarian states and um
in you know like hopeful idealistic
systems somehow leading to the suffering
of millions and i you know
this might be arguable but i think a lot
of people
believe that stalin
i think genuinely believed that he's
doing good for the world
and uh he wasn't
it's a very valuable lesson that um
even evil people
think they're doing good
uh otherwise it's too difficult to do
the evil
the best way to do evil is to believe
framing in a way like you're doing good
and then this is this is a very clear
picture of that which is the the gulags
and soldiers is one of the best people
to reveal that yeah
the most recent thing i read it isn't
actually fiction uh was the
the woman i can't remember her name who
got the nobel prize about
within the last five years
i don't know whether she's ukrainian or
russian
but their
interviews have you read that interview
of ukrainian uh survivors of well i
think she may be originally ukrainian
the book's written in russian and then
translated into english and
many of the interviews are in moscow and
places
but she won the nobel prize within the
last five years or so
but what's interesting is that uh
these are people of all different ages
all different uh
occupations and so forth and they
reflecting on the
their reaction to
basically the present soviet system the
system they lived with before there's a
lot of
uh looking back by a lot of them with
uh
well
it being much better before
you